what I want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with the notion of
a set and also perform some operations
on sets so a set is really just a
collection of the distinct objects so
for example I could have a set let's say
let's call this set X and let's say and
I'll deal with numbers right now but a
set could contain anything it could take
contain colors it could contain people
that could contain other sets it could
contain cars it could contain farm
animals but the numbers will be easy to
deal with just because well they're
their numbers so let's say I have a set
X and it has the distinct objects in it
3 the number 3 the number 12 the number
5 and the number 13 that right there is
a set I could have another set let's
call that set Y I didn't have to call it
Y I could have called it a I could have
called it Sal I could have called it a
bunch of different things but I'll just
call it Y and let's say that set Y it's
it's a collection of the distinct
objects the number 14 the number 15 the
number 6 and the number 3 so fair enough
those are just two set definitions the
way that we typically do it in
mathematics is we put these little curly
brackets around the objects that are
separated by commas now let's do some
basic operations on sets and the first
operation that I will do is called
intersection and so we would say X we
would say X intersect the intersection
of x and y X intersect Y and the way
that I think about this this is going to
yield another set this is going to yield
another set that contains the elements
that are in both x and y so I often view
I often view this intersection symbol
right here as and so all of the things
that are in X and in Y so what are those
things going to be well let's look at
both sets x and y so the number 3 is in
set X is it in set y as well well sure
it's
both it's in both so it will be in the
intersection of X & Y now the number 12
that's in set X but it isn't in Y so
we're not going to include that the
number 5 it's an X but it's not in Y and
then we have the number 13 is in X but
it's not in Y and so over here the
intersection of x and y is the set that
only has one object in it it only has
the number 3 so we are done the
intersection of x and y is 3 now another
common operation on sets is Union so you
could have the union of X x and y and
the Union I often view or people often
view as or so we're thinking about all
of the elements that are in X or Y so in
some ways you can kind of imagine that
we're bringing these two sets together
so this is going to be this is going to
be and the key here is is that we care a
set is a collection of distinct objects
and the way we're conceptually right
conceptualizing things right here this
is the number 3 this isn't like somebody
score on a test or the number of apples
they have so there you could have
multiple people with the same number of
apples here we're talking about the
object the number 3 so we can only have
a 3 once but a 3 is in set is in X or Y
so I'll put a 3 there a 12 is in X or Y
a 5 is in X or Y the 13 is in X or Y and
just to simplify things we really don't
care about order if we're just talking
about a set I've just put all the things
that are in set X here and now let's see
what we have to add from set Y so we
haven't put a 14 yet so let's put a 14
we haven't put a 15 yet we haven't put
the 6 yet and we already have a 3 in our
set so there you go you have the union
of x and y and one way to visualize sets
and visualize intersections and unions
and more complicated things is using a
Venn diagram so let's let's say this
whole box is you could
that is the set of all numbers so that's
all the numbers right over there we have
set X set X I'll just draw as a circle
right over here and I can even draw the
elements of set X so you have 3 & 5 & 12
3 5 12 and 13 and then we can draw a set
Y we can draw a set Y and notice I drew
a little overlapping here because they
overlap at 3 3 is an element in both set
X and set Y but set Y also has the
numbers 14 15 and 6 and so when we're
talking about X intersect Y we're
talking about where the two sets in
overlap so we're talking about this
region right over here and the only
place that they overlap the way I've
drawn it is at the number 3 so this is X
intersect X intersect Y and then X Union
Y is the combination of these two sets
so X Union Y is literally everything
everything right here that we are
combining let's do one more example just
so that we make sure we understand
intersection and union so let's say that
I have set a and set a is has the
numbers 11 4 12 and 7 in it and I have
set B I have set B and it has the
numbers 13 4 12 10 and 3 in it so first
of all let's think about what a a will
be than a scholar let's think about what
a intersect a intersect B is going to be
equal to well it's the things that are
in both sets so I have 11 here I don't
have an 11 there so that doesn't that
doesn't make the intersection I have a 4
here I also have a 4 here so 4 is an A
and be it's an A&B so I'll put a 4 here
the number 12 it's in a and B so I'll
put a 12 here number Seven's only in a
the number like 13 10 and 3 is only in B
so we're done 4 and 12 the set of 4 and
12 is the intersection of sets a and B
and we could even if we want to we could
even label this as a new set we could
say set C is the intersection of a and B
and it's this set right over here now
let's think about Union let's think
about a a I want to do that in orange
let's think about a union a union B what
are all the elements that are in a or b
a or b well we can just when we put all
the elements in a 11 for 12 7 and then
put the things in B that aren't already
in a so C 13 we already put the 4 in the
12 a 10 and a 3 and I could write this
in any order I want we don't care about
order if we're thinking about a set so
this right here is the Union